foreign
[Music]
come on dog you know how we do TNT with
lime we're not open until noon it is
noon it's 11 57. now what time is it 11
56.
[Applause]
good Lord you need to fire her I can't
fire her she has a disability what no I
don't you don't no that's the reason why
I heard you
Uber driver and I don't have a car
come on up his parents said if I quote
date their son they'd give me a Buick
Regal you won't even rent your house out
but now you're going to rent out your
badge you have a roadrunner tattoo
covering your entire back I don't think
you should tell anybody what to do with
their body nope
I'm going to teach you how to have fun
am I allowed to be here I can't be
scared of everything your whole life
[__] Maddie Barker your little
disappearing act that was the best thing
that ever happened to me congratulations
is her vagina dishwasher safe she's a
real person what part of Russia did they
ship her from
she's Russian no
um
you need to learn how to party
have you seen Percy Percy Percy Percy
doesn't anyone [__] anymore
[Music]
oh my god did you [__] him I like your
house a lot it's cozy ooh we should have
some music
dance party
[Music]
on my legs
yeah this is good
[Music]
okay